?
>> YEAH.
>> IF NO EMBIID, HAWKS IN FIVE.
>> I ALREADY HAVE A DIFFERENT
COMMENTARY ABOUT TONIGHT.
WE'VE ALL GROWN UP AND EVEN
HISTORIANS AND EVEN ON THE GRAM
AND ALL OF THESE PLACES, YOU SEE
THE HISTORIC WILLIS REED COMING
BACK AND PLAYING IN THAT GAME.
>> ISAIAH, FOURTH QUARTER.
>> PLAYING HURT, HE'S LIMPING.
>> ISAIAH GOT HURT DURING THE
MIDDLE OF THE GAME.
YOU KNOW, WALT FRAZIER HAD 36
POINTS AND 19 ASSISTS.
THAT WAS THE REASON.
>> WILLIS HIT TWO QUICK BUCKETS.
>> THAT'S IT.
I THINK IN THE CURRENT TIME YOU
HAVE TO PREPARE.
WHEN YOU'RE PREPARING FOR AN
OPPONENT IN A CLOSEOUT GAME AND
YOU THINK A GUY IS GOING TO
PLAY, THEN EVERYONE'S
PREPARATION IS DIFFERENT.
GASOL, YOU'RE GOING TO START
TONIGHT.
DRUMMOND, YOU'RE ON THE BENCH.
EVERYONE IS DIFFERENT NOW.
FOR ME, I THINK THE LACK OF
PREPARATION WHERE I AGREE WITH
CHUCK, HE SHOULD HAVE NEVER EVEN
PLAYED.
IF YOU WATCH A GUY IN THE FIRST
TWO MINUTES, WHAT IS HE DOING
OUT THERE?
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE A DOCTOR TO
SEE THAT HE SHOULDN'T BE OUT
THERE.
>> I'M REALLY PISSED ABOUT THAT.
>> YOU CAN'T PREPARE.
>> HE CAN'T MAKE IT ANY WORSE.
YES, YOU CAN.
ANY TIME YOU'RE HURT AND YOU GOT
SOMETHING GOING ON WITH YOUR
LEGS, YOU'RE GOING TO HURT
ANOTHER PART OF YOUR BODY.
THEY SAID THE DOCTOR CLEARED HIM
TO PLAY.
THEY NEED SOME BETTER DOCTORS.
>> 62-41 IS YOUR HALFTIME SCORE.
IT'S GAME 6.
IF THE SUNS WIN, THEY INTO THE
WESTERN CONFERENCE SEM